if you actually put a little effort into
it it usually turns out better than when
you just kind of pull it out of your
wherever i don't know we've had some of
our best superlative segments when we
pull it out of our butt
i have a feeling i have a feeling that's
what about yours is going to be so we
can contrast the two of ours go ahead
first well i'm gonna give the uh
our matey walk the plank award okay to
the oakland raiders you gotta walk
though the las vegas raiders sorry you
gotta walk the plank
you gotta you lost you got covered too
get off this ship uh but either way okay
i got it i hope it is worse than scurvy
i know sorry i i had to take that little
shot there but i mean really i want to
talk about the tampa bay buccaneers i
mean they made the las vegas raiders in
the battle of the pirate buccaneer patch
game whatever uh they made them walk the
plank and the buccaneers as you said you
know earlier in the show and something
we've been saying for the last week
more and more just look like to me they
look like the most complete team in the
nfc there's not a weakness to their
football team they're really not and
with john gruden and their o-line having
you know lack of practice man this isn't
the team you want to have lack of
practice against not that buccaneers
front seven that's as good as anybody in
football and you know we played the clip
with gruden talking about lack of pass
rush yeah that's you know that's the
problem with the raiders they their
fronts their front is not good it's it's
below average front
and that's just not good either when
you're playing tom brady in that
buccaneers offensive line
that is really playing good and can
dominate you in the run game and then
can protect him all day long too i mean
brady he looked phenomenal yesterday i
mean i don't think he threw one ball
where i went oh that wasn't a perfect
spiral he put that right where he wanted
to i mean he was very very impressive i
mean a ton of pep in his arm still um
but i i again just go back to them and
right now i just go man when it comes to
offense balance running the ball short
passing game deep passes defense being
able to stop the run
and make plays
turnovers
they can trust their corners in
man-to-man situations
i i don't who else can you say that
about in the nfc right now i don't think
there's another team you can talk about
that like so to me
you know the bucks are just more and
more every week it just goes ooh watch
out there might be the best team in the
nfc after last night you're going to put
them ahead of them you're going gonna
put them ahead of the seahawks now
whatever uh yes yes i i i we'll see
about the power rankings maybe maybe
okay but but let me say this yeah
whatever the league does to the raiders
whatever it may be and it's not quite
clear what the league is going to do
generally when it comes to teams that
have coveted 19 protocol violations of
four schedule changes the titans were
fined 350 000 there are people around
the league who were stunned that it was
only 350 000 because the league was
sending out very clear messages to teams
that they were going to hammer the
titans and there's a theory out there
that the titans pushed back hard the
titans pushed back aggressively and the
titans may have found some sort of a
flaw in the investigation that caused
the nfl to back off and only find them
350 000 for causing two different games
to be moved and for causing the facility
to be shut down for an extended stretch
now people are wondering what happens to
the raiders for all the stuff that
they've had go wrong the accumulation of
covet 19 violations but you know what
the the worst punishment may have been
to force john gruden
to play the buccaneers yeah at a time
when he thinks his guys are unprepared
right and i feel like that's part of
this
this effort by the nfl to address teams
and this kind of gets to your point of
just make them forfeit if they're not
ready to go yeah make them go play if
they're not ready make them go play if
they're starting offensive line didn't
practice all week because they were put
into the enhanced coveted uh contact
list protocol where they're not allowed
to be around the team and and that may
have been punishment enough i was told
yesterday morning john gruden was livid
that they had to go forward with that
game on sunday he wanted to be monday or
tuesday i wanted it to be monday or
tuesday because i wanted to watch it
yeah me too you saw it yesterday it's a
405 regional kick eastern time but uh
that may be the pun and the other thing
i think the reason they push forward
with it if you delay it by a day or two
you never know how many positives are
going to pop up in the next few days
with the raiders let's get this game
played
while the planets are lined up let's
play this damn game and move on to next
week yeah
that's right and again i mean
i'm not
i want again why
why let these teams off the hook with
some of this
i mean i do i mean again
you know the raiders of all team are not
the ones who are going to give a free
pass to not at this point i mean okay
you've already used your free pass you
already got your get out of jail free
card that's that's you lost that now you
had to play and yeah that stinks it
really does it was a horrible group to
have entered too in that football game
wow to have to deal with that but
um yeah i was surprised tennessee i
heard some of the same things you did i
thought tennessee was gonna get the
hammer laid down on them i don't know
but maybe this is what the nfl does
going forward they kind of just force
the issue and make your team play
yeah i think that's part of the
punishment yeah just got to play you
you're not ready too bad right you had
five guys missed the whole week of
practice too bad you got this going on
too bad you got to play i know yeah
that's it's it's a it's a it's a subtle
and indirect homage to one of the best
scenes in goodfellas but we can't use
the language that they use
in uh in that film so uh anyway um
another another point from that game
yesterday yeah rob gronkowski is another
little on the fly trivia question for
you rob gronkowski and tom brady now
including the postseason this is
courtesy of the nfl's seven from sunday
excellent service they put out every
every sunday night with statistical
significance and oddities from the games
gronk and brady have combined for 92
touchdown
passes regular season and post season
that ties them
with who
for second most all-time quarterback
receiver i want to say
it's not is that jerry and it's either
jerry and steve or peyton and marvin i'm
gonna say it's jerry and steve right
well well ding ding ding and first place
with 114
is the other two
peyton and marvin peyton marvin 114
steve young jerry rice 92
brady and gronk mike 92 mike
gronk's back
he's back like he looked he looked like
gronk yesterday to me just the way he
ran
i mean just it just he's finally out of
mud i don't you know like you talked
about early in the year but like his
knees can actually lift in the air and
run now
and running over the middle taking big
shots
like that was like whoa okay yep we've
seen this story before it might be a
different city and we were patriots but
now we're buccaneers so what same damn
combination
like i'm not saying he's back to the
gronk five years ago but he's he's back
to the gronk of oh wait we're playing
the bucks we have to have a plan for him
in certain situations and formations and
that's just another weapon to go with
antonio brown mike evans and chris
godwin and leonard fournette and jones
and all that like watch out bucks
but but here's part of the problem yeah
and and and i love bruce arians but ba's
been spewing plenty of bs this year and
it was back in august where he said that
gronk looks like he did five years ago
so
okay coach
let's see it
and and he is in slow motion for the
first six weeks of the season and now
he's finally starting to come around so
it takes three months for him to get in
football shape but but don't tell us he
looks like he looks like he did five
years ago because he doesn't and uh uh
but but he's getting there and that's
good news
for the buccaneers especially with oj
howard out for the year and now antonio
what's your join the team what's your
next superlative you stayed up all night
for can you get to it already it seems
like you're delaying this forever and
you're talking about i haven't gotten to
one yet yeah look now how about this
okay how about what about this well i
got my notes here i want to pick the
best one i got a bunch to choose from i
got like 10 of them how about the
bizarro brian westbrook award do you
know what i'm referring to oh i saw
brian westbrook the the old todd gurley
didn't put the brakes on quick enough
for it
and it was 2007 it was an eagles cowboys
game and the eagles were leading late
and if you score the cowboys get the
ball back and in theory they could score
get an onside kick and
you're better off keeping possession and
killing the clock so westbrook went down
and and it was smart and it was
unselfish and it runs counter to
everything that we want to see in
today's fantasy football driven nfl
todd gurley tried
to do that yesterday against the detroit
lions tried is the key word creating one
of the all-time great nfl visuals where
todd gurley tries to stop short
fails to stop short crosses the goal
line and it's a member of the lion's
defense
who is in celebratory fashion throwing
his hands up saying
touchdown it's unbelievable and there's
a photo of that making the rounds that
it's just
weird to see it and it's awesome to see
it and todd gurley is very upset
that he did it
but but it runs counter to everything as
a football player especially a guy's
been through a few rough years you want
to go score a touchdown
how do you stop yourself from doing it
well
sometimes you don't and there's gurley
landing in the end zone and there's the
shot of jamie collins yeah touchdown and
you know what that's meaningless if the
lions don't win the game what makes that
is the lions ultimately use that as the
opening to win the game it it it was
it's amazing it's a it's unreal i mean
he's he's a smart football player i
believe we've seen him do this before i
can't remember the game
there was a game in the last two years
where you think you're right you know i
stopped at the one yard line honestly
you know the the thing that he has he
gets somebody is about to tackle him at
the five yard line
and i think he thought the guy was gonna
bring him down
and the guy kind of fell off and i think
it kind of like he got caught by
surprise where he thought like i think
i'm going down and the guy fell off
and he like oh no my momentum from
running through the tackle and all that
kind of i don't know it was just it
seemed that way we'll see either way but
that was an unbelievable turning turn of
the vets because then matt stafford just
makes some unbelievable plays to get
them down there and that was uh pretty
cool good for detroit all right you good
am i on to uh my next one you're up what
do you got next well
i want to give like the uh
you know
the freddie mercury award or the queen
award because they're they're more than
a one-man band you know how like freddie
mercury and queen he tried to go do his
own thing and he realized damn i'm not
as good unless i'm with the band all
right well like
yeah he kind of had his own moment where
he went off and did his own thing and
then he said i messed up i want to come
back and then they had a great concert
at the end right i mean damn watch the
movie okay but either way um
the kansas city chiefs yeah they're more
than a one-man band they're not they are
this is why the kansas city chiefs are
unbelievable to me they are i mean
patrick mahomes he it was a snooze fest
for him yesterday he had to do nothing
in that football game but it doesn't
matter the kansas city chiefs got play
makers everywhere it just oh kick return
touchdown oh interception return
touchdown oh frank clark you know
intercepting a pass and setting them up
in a good way to score that way i mean
it's just amazing again kansas city we
think about them all the time as this
high-flying act but yet when they need
to be physical or play dirty or their
defense needs to have a big stop they're
capable of doing that and that's why
they're so dangerous to me and you know
hey le'veon bell that looked good all
that stuff so i thought that was a cool
win for kansas city showed they're
capable of kind of doing it in more than
one way
and patrick holmes loves playing in the
snow and they got it and we saw that
coming it wasn't as bad as i thought it
was going to be and of course the worse
it is the better it is when it comes to
snow but it was still
just enough and it was jarring to look
at the calendar and see october 25 and
to see that kind of snow but that's kind
of how it is in denver yeah it is it'll
be 80 degrees one day and
it'll be three feet of snow the next day
it will all right next one for me and
i know last hour we spent a lot of time
praising the current state of the
pittsburgh steelers and
for good reason
they're they're awesome they're unbeaten
they look great they're going to be 13-3
or better
but
this award is called stop scouting
receivers and start scouting
quarterbacks
because
i've seen the future for pittsburgh and
it is being in a division
without ben roethlisberger
and facing joe burrow baker mayfield and
lamar jackson twice a year and
yesterday's browns bengals game you
didn't know where i was going there did
you i didn't either i thought you were
going to go back to the do they need a
quarterback of the future from that mike
florio book i thought that's where you
might have been going to
can i can i finish
um they better they better be ready to
replace ben roethlisberger because they
went 20 years between terry bradshaw and
ben roethlisberger with a lot of
of not very good quarterbacks some guys
who were okay but not good enough and
and then finally in 2004 21 years after
terry bradshaw retired they went top 11
pick on ben roethlisberger they better
have a plan
because look hey we had plenty of
criticism for baker mayfield he was the
real deal yesterday after a slow start i
mean he was 0 for 5 and then he went 22
for 23 down the stretch and won the game
against the bengals joe burrow was
awesome 406 passing yards lamar jackson
is lamar jackson i'm just telling you i
don't know how long roethlisberger's got
left
but they better have a plan because this
afc north for all we say about the nfc
west this afc north is for real and you
got some great quarterbacks and the
steelers had better be ready to try to
get you know a brett favre aaron rodgers
hand off and not wait 20 years between
franchise quarterback yeah well that
better happen this year next year it's
it's gotta it's gotta happen here soon
in the next two or three years you're
right and it ain't mason rudolph no and
it's not josh dobbs and it's not doc
hodges it's none of the guys floating
around now they need to find they need
to i think they just need to wait until
ben's done because he won't accept the
fact if they have and they're not going
to have a high first round pick the way
they're playing
but yeah it's it's it's listen that's
the thing that would keep me up at night
i'm going to be enjoy this season if i'm
a steelers fan but the thing i'd be
worried about is holy crap within a few
years
we could be the team that's in last
place in this division yeah well you
know hopefully not hopefully they'll see
the future the good thing is with all
the quarterbacks coming out in the draft
and you know i mean it already looks
like there'll be a long list of
quarterbacks and free agency next year
and things like that you know maybe they
can find a stop gap guy either way but
pittsburgh is really good i was going to
go there
you know with my next superlative you
know because you're what what the hell
was your superlative there stop scouting
receivers start scouting quarterbacks
award
good thing you stayed up all night for
that one good thing you stayed up for
that tonight
just stall i'm gonna sit down and come
up with something creative right now at
12 45. that's not crazy
that's not creative
i maybe could have found a better way to
say it all right i mean should i have
done it in a pirate voice it wasn't as
cool as our matey right exactly i know
that's my reference my freddie you know
freddie merc i'm on fire today i'm
killing it i do want to go back to one
of the seven superlatives you just
mentioned in your one superlative there
[Laughter]
i want to go to you know they call it if
they're going to call it you saw the
sign in the game right with the bangles
browns yesterday joe ohio okay it could
be joe ohio then it's got to be baker
natty
does that sound good baker and addie
baker natty something like that i'm
trying to make a play on baker own
cincinnati yesterday
i i think we get that got the point okay
you know baker natty i think that sounds
good all right but either way i mean
baker mayfield we got to give him credit
for what he did yesterday i mean we've
been all over him it's been very up and
down and probably more down this year
than anything but yesterday especially
the way it started the interception on
the first throw of the game oh and fi oh
for five it really looked like joe
burrow and company had it clicking baker
mayfield just answered the bell time
after time after time and like you said
he ends the game 22 of 23 and his one
and completion was a spike to stop the
clock but a lot of big time throws like
not easy slam dunk throws either like oh
it's one on one 30 yards down the field
bam on the money oh it's one on one 15
20 yards down the middle bam on the
money so good for baker mayfield and
what he did yesterday that was a big
bounce back win for the browns
yeah it really is amazing and that game
was back and forth and that's one that i
look forward to watching very carefully
to see what happened why it happened how
it happened really is amazing bingo
bingo
really is amazing what
it really is amazing bingo i think
that's one of our baking bingo ones is
it one of mine is it one of yours you
add some to yours we've missed some of
yours
i'm just going to say i am i'm i'm i i
i'm gonna say it i am i okay 20 years
yeah yeah no all right uh next one
um
you're familiar with the concept of
snake oil right
the uh
yeah the snake oil the the cure-all uh
that does absolutely nothing well the
the jaguars have their own brand of
snake oil which actually works i'll call
it shod khan's crappy football team
tonic all you have to do if you're a bad
football team is play the jaguars and
you win it's amazing every game they've
played since winning week one against
the colts has been against a team that's
winless or entered the game with one win
and the jaguars have lost to that team i
mean that if you are down and out
schedule the jaguars and you will get a
win the chargers pulled it off yesterday
and the jaguars are off this week
they've got the one in six texans the
next time they play great news for the
texans and and look i love doug marone i
love doug uh dave caldwell i i love him
enough that i know his name um
they're into their bye week and there's
been no talk about this i wouldn't be
surprised if at some point today
gone gone how can this house is
sustainable what have you seen from the
jaguar since week one that that makes
you look at it and say this is
sustainable no i know i mean i mean yes
i don't know what they expected this is
the results i expected i mean this is
where i thought they'd be one in six two
and five something like that
you know again where where what what is
there to hang your hat on you know
that's that's the big thing yeah there's
some young cool talent on the team that
doesn't mean crap in 2020 nfl
you know there's a lot of you know
middle-aged good talent on all the other
teams and they're better so i you know
again
yes it's they're in a tough spot and i
was a little surprised this regime came
back in general anyways this year uh and
it seemed like it was a weird fake
rebuild or i don't know whatever the
hell it was the one thing i do want to
hit on that game though just one more
time with your jacksonville chargers
game um this justin
justin herbert's really good like really
freaking good like wow
i mean you know you saw yesterday they
took the training wheels off stop trying
to run the ball on first and second down
just let him throw let him go a little
bit he he can do it all so that was
impressive
yeah uh and and uh i think that's one of
the big reasons why tuatanga vilo is
going to be playing yeah i think
dolphins come out of there by this week
we got to see what this guy has because
my goodness what justin herbert has and
the dolphins could have had him that's
the thing that's a great coast
to coast apples to apples comparison the
dolphins took tua they could have had
herbert and herbert is great for the la
chargers all right you got any more
um i don't have a creative word for it
but uh let's say you might let's give it
to you might want to double that guy
award okay um yeah let's see um green
bay yesterday aaron rodgers there's no
aaron jones rodney harrison made the
great point last night there's no aaron
jones wait and devonte adams is in the
game so i wonder who they'll give the
ball a lot to in the football game huh
oh that's right devonte adams i mean
holy crap did what did the texans think
aaron rodgers and green bay were gonna
do like feature sternberger in the game
i mean what the hell do they think
they're gonna do how many times do they
have to get burned by devante adams
before they went maybe we should do
something else but rogers and devonte
adams were en fuego yesterday i mean
they really were rogers proved that last
week was an anomaly he seemed like he
was on a mission all week but you know
beating that you know into everybody's
brain it was an anomaly his anomaly
we're still really good well he
certainly you know proved that point or
at least shut people up who were
doubting it a little bit and devonte
adams when he's healthy and hitting on
all cylinders you know they're just
third different football team because
him and rogers do have a special
connection so
that was pretty awesome that was dicing
them up yesterday by those two
think of how spectacular it could be if
adams could stay on the field yeah time
last year right he missed time this year
and he wasn't and maybe the texans just
kind of misread the film from last week
and they thought oh devante adams has
missed some time he you know he's kind
of missing just a little something well
he's worked his way back into shape and
the texans paid for it in a big way but
you're right aaron jones is out how in
the hell are you not taking away devante
adams because it's not like there's
you know a first round receiver they
drafted like justin jefferson or someone
who could burn them um
by their own design i'm shocked packers
shocks packers back on track yeah rogers
called it an anomaly last week you know
he said it was a wake-up call at the
time and hey they didn't let it turn
into two losses they went to houston and
took care of business yeah they did they
they looked good yesterday they did and
of course i mean we know that's not a
huge a very good houston football team i
mean we understand that i i was
surprised though that i thought i
thought we would get at some point to
this game but like desean watson makes
some magic happen and oh it's here in
the fourth quarter and it is a one score
game but it never got to that i mean
green bay's defense looked like it did a
good job of bottling up watson from
making like extending plays all those
type of things all game long and it just
seemed like every time rogers dropped
back to pass he was gashing them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports